We often highlight women on our show
who aren't afraid to color outside the lines.
We actually call them wild flowers.
And because today is International Women's Day,
we are teaming up with Wounded Warrior Project
to introduce you to a rose who is anything but delicate.
Meet Donna.
(upbeat music)
My name is Donna Pratt,
and I am from O'Fallon, Illinois.
I am a retired Army Sergeant,
and I am a woman veteran warrior.
When I joined the military right after high school
I decided that the army wasn't for me then.
I got out in 1998.
But after 9/11, I decided to rejoin
'cause I felt like there was something more
that I needed to be doing.
We were deployed to Iraq.
I got a chance to be at armor.
We had a vehicle that was jarred up and down.
And a few weeks later I had swollen ankles
and didn't pay attention
'cause I had a job that I needed to do.
Walked into the clinic,
and had fractures, torn ligaments, nerve damage,
and doctor's telling me most likely
I wouldn't be able to walk again,
which was devastating news.
I was in a wheelchair for about two years.
I went through several bouts of surgeries,
physical therapy and prayer.
I was asked to come to a Wounded Warrior Project
soldier ride, which is a bicycle ride.
I thought they were crazy.
I went on that bike ride.
It helped me gain a sense of myself
that I didn't even know I had,
that being in a wheelchair wasn't my death sentence.
Sports at Wounded Warrior Project
brought me out of depression
and brought me out of a sense of
not even wanting to be alive.
Now I'm happy, I got a chance to be married,
and now I'm carrying other warriors by telling my story
to know that no matter what life isn't impossible.
I developed a motto for myself.
I don't adapt to life.
I make life adapt to me.
(audience applauding)
I love that motto so much.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)